you know but before we talk about the
teams that are still left that are
playing for the super bowl in kansas
city and tampa why don't we talk for a
second guys about the teams that got
knocked out
uh let's start with green bay mike do
you make anything of the the aaron
rodgers we're not sure was that heat of
the moment what do you think that was
well i think now that i've had a couple
of days to think about to talk about it
here his follow-up i can boil it down to
this
i think that after what happened last
year with the drafting of quarterback
jordan love aaron rodgers wants clarity
as to where he stands is jordan love
destined to be the next jimmy garoppolo
who gets traded eventually to another
team while the older quarterback keeps
going strong or is jordan love the next
aaron rodgers who eventually takes over
for the older quarterback when they go
to him and say
thanks for the memories but we're ready
to move on
and
with favre the strategy was ask him
whether he was all in for the next
season at a time when they knew he would
retire so it worked easily when they
wanted to move to rogers but rogers
wants to know where he fits and to get
the clarity i think he'd like a
commitment to get the commitment you get
a new contract that makes it impossible
to treat him like a year to year player
which is i think how the packers
currently view him he wants something
more clear than that i think that's
where it all stands
well mike's got a lot more uh
inside information than i do but i read
it as kind of taking a shot and getting
prepared for the draft a preemptive shot
hey last year we're in the same position
we lost in the championship game i
thought we were ready to roll we just
needed a couple more pieces to the
puzzle and you got me a
backup quarterback
i think we're in the same boat but i
don't want to go through that again so
let's make sure we're all on the same
page what do we need to go forward uh
let's have some certainty and clarity in
that i think he wants to be there
expects to be there he wants them to
draft him some weapons
yeah maybe more messaging than movement
what about buffalo tony how close are
they when you take a step back
you know it's uh it's funny i talked to
leslie frazier uh after the game and i
just shook my head and said wow that you
know i've been there before where you
kind of get in that last game and you
get steamrolled but you are very close
and they played some great football down
the stretch they lost two games to the
chiefs so you know you've got to close
that gap but that's a good football team
and they're going to be back and believe
me that this year with josh allen and
just the confidence that that team now
has in their quarterback uh that's going
to go a long ways in 2021.
my caveat to that though is and i heard
cbs on the way off the air praising the
bills and saying they'll be right back
here next year i i'd look around a
little bit before coming to that
conclusion the dolphins are improving
the patriots are still the patriots the
jets with robert sala could start
getting better and other teams in the
conference could be improved look last
year we thought the 49ers would just
punch the ticket again and be at the top
of the nfc so a lot of things can
conspire to turn a special season into a
not special season for the bills and
that's why it hurts so bad when you get
that close when you're on the porch and
the door is open and you don't get a
chance to walk through it that's what
makes it difficult because here's where
i agree with aaron rodgers there are no
absolutes there are no guarantees when
it comes to your ability to get back to
the level that you got to this year
yeah that's one of those you're leaving
you say oh they'll be back because they
feel like they're really close but
there's a lot that goes with it there
are other good teams that they need a
pass rusher
they need somebody who can impact the
game off the edge speaking of which as
we get to kansas city tampa bay tony i
want to go right to you not on what they
did but where they're going
the tackle play is going to be really
big in this game one of the things that
was talked about enough green bay missed
david bakhtiari and all pro left tackle
a lot in the game against tampa and now
here's kansas city without both of their
regular tackles how big a problem is
that
that's going to be a huge problem mike
you and i were up in green bay and we
were marveling at their offensive line
play and how good they were and how
solid it was and at that time david
bakiyari had not given up a sack all
year and
boy we're rock solid he goes down with
an injury and now you put a new left
tackle in who's not quite as good
a couple of pressures app gets a couple
of pressures now we've got to adjust
we've been letting that left tackle
block by himself all year sliding to the
right well now we've got to help the
left tackle well now all of a sudden the
right tackle has some problems with shaq
barrett and that's the way it can
steamroll and if i know andy reid is
concerned about that
they had an injury to mitchell schwartz
right tackle was outstanding and played
all year without him and done a great
job of adjusting not all year but most
of the year now all of a sudden eric
fisher gets hurt now we've got to move
mike remembers who was that fell in
right tackle we got to move him to the
left side andrew wiley our right guard
has to move out the right tackle stephen
wisniewski comes in so we're actually
not as good at three spots now because
of one injury and you're playing against
the defensive line that has play makers
that's going to be an issue and how well
can they hold up and block for patrick
mahomes in this game
you know even if they struggle one of
the realities is you still have to get
to mahomes and we had robert sala on pft
live today and i asked him what advice
would you give to the buccaneers
defensive lineman because he coached the
guys last year who we thought were all
good enough big enough fast enough to
give mahomes fits and salah said you've
got to be relentless because he'll take
those last couple steps backward and
then throw the ball and he'll do the old
man jog between plays so you think maybe
he's not as as fast and elusive as he
really is and then once he has the ball
in his hands you can't go get him and
and that's going to be the challenge
even with issues in the blocking mahomes
is so slippery it's so hard to get a
beat on him that's going to be the
challenge for jpp shaq barrett and
dominic and sue anyone else that they
managed to get through that front wall
tony i thought tampa's defense was okay
when we saw them against washington in
the wild card round
but the addition of devon white and the
value of that top 10 player at his speed
was so evident in the two following
playoff games
they do things with those linebackers
that they have some of the speed there
the question is can the back end hold up
against all the kansas city myriad of
options on offense
no it was funny because when we did that
washington game everybody all the
coaches all the players told us yeah
devin's not going to be there we know
that but we're going to be okay we this
guy's going to fill in and we'll do this
and
he does make a huge difference when you
saw him in the lineup and making those
plays and running sideline the sideline
and calling the defenses
he is special
but
against kansas city it's how do you
match up in that back end who can cover
uh those receivers who can cover tyreke
hill
when the ball is going to come out fast
but you know it's coming to them who can
cover travis kelsey so you can have all
of that together in the front seven you
can get pressure on my homes you can
stuff the running game but it's going to
come down to how does our back end
survive and in that first game they
really didn't
you know the thing that devin white
impresses me the most with is just his
his overall
intensity he's chippy but he's not too
chippy he's in your face but he's not
too in your face
and and he finds a way to lift the whole
defense we saw it kick in the second
half of the game against the saints we
saw it all game long against the packers
and i think that that that defense is
going to go as far as he can take it as
much as he can lift it he's got to be
that x factor you know delivering
something that sets the tone early and
gets the chiefs a little wobbly i think
it falls to him and if he can pull it
off then this game ends up being a lot
closer than than it otherwise would be
when you consider how good the kansas
city offense is
yeah mike he does bring an attitude to
that defense that is a little different
let me just unpack kansas city for a
second mike i'll start with you with
eric b enemy uh you know we talk about
coaches and not getting opportunities
and all this stuff and eric b enemy
we all know what he does for andy reid
we all know that he handles all the red
zone install and play design down there
in the red zone who's been better in the
reds in the last couple of years than
the chiefs and yet
it looks like we might get to the end of
another hiring cycle with eric b enemy
not getting an opportunity
what is being heard what's being said
regarding this issue as we look at the
coaching openings in the bigger picture
now
i think most people look at it and you
look at the various openings you look at
the people who have been hired you look
at the names of guys that have gotten
interviews like josh mccown and i love
josh mccown but he's got no business
being interviewed for a head coaching
job with the texans or anyone else at
the nfl level
and i think people are just kind of
resigned it's kind of like okay well all
right i guess next year the the window
is going to open for eric the enemy i
don't know what more he needs to do
though to convince someone that he's the
right guy to pair up with a quarterback
ideally a young quarterback and mold him
into
a guy who will perform like patrick
mahomes now it may not be the same skill
set but you get the most out of what the
guy does you design plays that are aimed
to draw out his strengths and conceal
whatever weaknesses he may have and i i
just don't get it and part of me feels
like and coach you may know this better
than anyone
i just feel like these owners don't like
being told what to do and i just feel
like at some level the more that the
rest of us say eric the enemy needs to
be hired the more they their attitude is
we'll do what we damn well please
well i don't think it's that necessarily
but everybody is looking for something
everybody has something they're looking
for and i i went through that interview
process
and the the thing that i learned from it
is
you might not be exactly what they're
looking for even though you're a good
candidate and that happened to me a
couple times um
i'll give you a for instance
jacksonville jaguars when they were
starting their franchise up wayne weaver
interviewed me and it was great and it
went well
and we came down to the end and he said
i'm really looking for one person to run
everything i'm looking for that that
person who's going to do it all be the
coach and the gm and i said well that's
not me i'm a coach i don't want to be a
gym i don't that's
that's just not me they hired tom
coughlin and it was a great decision for
them tom was exactly what wayne weaver
was looking for
the problem then comes is when people go
and say
why didn't you hire tony dungy
and instead of saying well you know he
wasn't exactly what we're looking for i
didn't think he was qualified to do this
this and this
then they said well you know we we don't
know and then it becomes well he was not
a good interview and i heard that after
you know a couple of mine after that
jacksonville so well maybe he doesn't
interview well
uh and and that's not it at all
sometimes it just hurts it's hard for
that person to say you know what we
interviewed eric the enemy we liked him
but we liked something in this other
guy's skill set a little more um and and
i think that's where eric is right now
matter of fact i had a long conversation
with rich mckay who did a search for
atlanta and interviewed eric b enemy and
he said he heard that
that eric didn't interview well he
called a couple of reporters and and
journalists and said
let me set the record straight eric
banning was phenomenal in the interview
i don't want to hear that but it just
wasn't what we were looking for we liked
arthur smith and we hired him but don't
trash eric the enemy
because we didn't hire it
tony does that help right there i'm
sorry mike where uh rich mckay will get
word out to other people that
this narrative is not true it wasn't a
fit but and that helps quell that
conversation that keeps building quote
he does an interview well
it absolutely does um
and those interviews help and i know
people don't like the rooney rule and
they they really think it's a problem
when guys interview and don't get jobs
but it does help i remember years back
leslie frazier who's kind of in the
cycle now he interviewed with bill
parcells bill parcells was in miami
making the decisions and
he and parcells had a difference of
philosophy you know we played small guys
and fast guys and built our defense on
speed and parcells was big guys three
four dominant up front just big physical
he said i don't know that i could play
your style but he called a few people
and said hey leslie frazier is really uh
he's fantastic and you you need to talk
to him he's got it it was didn't fit
with us but he's got some good things
and i liked him and that helped leslie
down the road as people said well guys
bill parcells could recommend them um
even though they didn't hire him maybe
he's somebody i need to talk to and so
yes when the rich mckays and the bill
parcells get that out there to the
people in the know it does make a
difference
here's what i'm struggling with
first of all how is eric b enemy not
what one of these teams is looking for
when you consider the pipeline that's
been established of andy reid assistance
in kansas city doug peterson was what
the eagles were looking for same guy
same demographic same everything not
calling the plays involved in the play
design doing the same things that eric b
enemy is doing and he got a super bowl
win for the eagles matt nagy
ended up being what the bears were
looking for and you look at the eagles
now with nick ciriani how is siriani who
they're looking for but not the enemy
and you look at the lions with dan camel
and biting off guys kneecaps how is that
what the lions are looking for and not
eric the enemy that's just what confuses
me
how is this got like whatever you think
you want how is this guy not someone
that makes you say forget about what we
want this is what we need
well mike um i i look at it that way and
i kind of chuckled i was going to write
my headline it's not eric b enemy's
fault it's andy reid's fault andy reid
has lost his touch
because from 2001 everybody he's hired
and put in that position we've said gosh
this is a great guy andy reed knows how
to pick offensive coordinators doug
peterson uh matt nagy uh all these guys
and and even before that in philadelphia
same thing brad childress you can go
back everybody that andy reed has picked
and put in that position has been
fantastic but now he doesn't know what
he's doing he picked a guy that's not
very good now and eric the enemy
a victim of their success and being in
these two cycles going all the way to
the super bowl you know mike you
mentioned that point there like the dan
campbell hire right
that screams to what tony was saying of
chris spielman was brought in as a
football guy to run the search are you
telling me that dan campbell's not a
chris spielman type guy so the tony's
point may have been good but we were
looking for a certain type you can kind
of see
those connections there not that the
enemy didn't bring that but when i was
listening to the the kneecap press
conference like you talked about dan
campbell that that connected okay this
guy and chris spielman had to connect
perfectly in the conversation let me let
me end here with this topic and we'll
keep the detroit and houston thing going
for a second
matthew stafford it comes out this
weekend that the lions are ready to move
on and stafford's ready to move on et
cetera et cetera and you've got this
entire quarterback bachelorette type set
up here that's gonna kind of run through
rose ceremonies throughout the entire uh
winter and spring
so mike let me start this
if you took matthew stafford and put him
in houston
what would it take for the lions to
trade with with uh houston for deshaun
watson oh they're one this year plus
what else
to make that happen well
i i think before we get to that point
mike we assume that deshaun watson would
want to go to detroit and you know
you've got to want to be at the place
where you're being traded or that team
is going to say well we're just
inheriting someone else's problem we're
getting a guy that doesn't want to be
here so assuming that watson would want
to go there then it becomes who else is
at the table other teams he'd be
interested in and and i think if the
texans ever decide to go through with
this you have desean watson list all the
teams he'd play for and then you
basically hold up his contract and you
hold an auction until somebody gives you
exactly what you're looking for the most
you get that's that's what you do so for
the lions it would have to be assuming
that he wants to play for the jets which
he reportedly does or he'd play for the
dolphins which he reportedly does which
of those teams plus any others he'd play
for
will come in with that first rounder
plus and and if that now look if the
texans want matthew stafford that gives
them an edge because then you get a
player out of it that's a known
commodity that you would like to have
you know that was the thing that came up
about the dolphins in tua maybe the dog
maybe the texans don't want to
so if you're going to trade to a for
desean it's not going to work maybe you
need to do a three-team deal so i it's
it's it all depends on
where deshawn watson wants to go and how
many other teams are in that mix and how
much they bid that price up until the
texans pull the trigger
there are so many teams
i'm going to throw out one with deshawn
that maybe a head scratcher you know i'm
sitting there saying where could he go
and who could he impact but imagine
deshawn watson in the rams offense and
with that defense
um
i don't know if it could ever be pulled
off but i think he'd be perfect for what
they've got going in the play action
rollout game and and with that defense
just the thought
and a good one too tony if you're
houston
you're detroit you have quarterbacks who
are being talked about being moved who
knows who the head coach is going to be
in houston maybe deshawn wants to stay
etc etc right
would you as a coach push management to
make sure that that guy gets traded to
the other conference
that he's out of your conference and you
rarely have to see him
ideally that's what you would like but
what what would happen and in matthew's
case it's going to be a coach who hasn't
had a history with him if i've been with
him then i want to see him go and
succeed i want to see him have a chance
because i built that that
rapport with him but yes if i'm just
coming in as as dan campbell i want to
get him as far away from from me as i
can so he doesn't come back and play us
and i agree with that i agree with that
completely because i don't know what
kind of animosity may be lingering
between the lions and stafford and how
much extra motivation he would have if
he were competing directly with the
lions and that just ultimately makes you
look bad for trading him if he ends up
being a thorn in your side going forward
as you try to qualify for playoff births
now with with three wild card births
you're competing with teams in other
divisions almost as much as you're
competing with teams in your own
division so i would want to get him out
of the conference
mike what's the biggest off-season move
that will help set the dominoes for
everything else
well i think knowing whether or not
the texans are going to entertain trade
offers for deshaun watson will be the
first one because i think that's the guy
who's going to generate the longest list
of suitors and who would be traded right
at the outset of the league year let's
get this one figured out and then all
the other quarterbacks will fall into
place after that so he's not yet asked
to be traded because he knows that once
he says those words you can't go back
but it looks like he's moving in that
direction and i think the next piece of
the puzzle is what they do with the head
coach and then they'll either get a
trade demand or they won't
so tony unless you have mahomes or josh
allen or like a really great established
quarterback does everyone else
have the conversation i'm talking like
15 20 teams do they all have the
conversation head coach gm team
president owner
hey do we want in on this do we make an
effort i think you have to yes i think
you have to have that conversation if
you have a feeling that he's on the
market hey here's a guy who we know can
this is not speculation we believe
trevor lawrence can do it and maybe he's
going to be like justin herbert but
we've seen this guy come in and play at
a high high level he's 25 years old
yes we've got to at least investigate
what would it take for us to get him
mike floyd to remember one thing
the salary cap is going down from last
year right teams don't do their
contracts with the idea that the salary
cap is going down they do it with the
idea the salary cap's going up so for
any of these quarterback musical chairs
capped charge of absorbing a guy and the
cap charge of moving the guy you have is
going to combine and it may make it too
much like for a team like the rams it
may be a combination that makes it
impossible
mike wouldn't this be a great year to
have the combine in indy can you imagine
all the chit-chat
around
the week of the combine oh my god moving
back and forth yes
i'm hearing this i heard hey i was out
last night you don't know what i heard
and it becomes a florio story and it
goes on for days so
all right enjoy enjoy the pro bowl this
week guys i know we all have that
done
before super bowl 55. have a great week
guys